[Music]
hey guys welcome to another installment
of Harry Potter theory you guys seem to
be really enjoying these top five most
powerful spells videos so I'm going to
keep creating them as requested in this
video I'm going to be discussing our
favorite transfiguration professor
Minerva McGonagall
we don't really hear all C of
McGonigle's power often but she's an
exceptionally talented witch with a wide
range of abilities while shittin in
Hogwarts she was most hound student of
her entire year she achieved top grades
in her newts and owls and showed
powerful magical ability from a very
young age without further ado here's the
list number five knowledge of the dark
arts this includes her knowledge of and
ability to defend against the dark arts
as well as her knowledge and ability to
cast dark spells if necessary not all
witches and wizards have sufficient
knowledge of these subjects and in
several instances McGonigle has proven
that she is capable when McGonagall
became headmaster like all Headmaster's
she inherited the responsibility of
casting protective enchantments over her
wards in the event of impending danger
this responsibility we require powerful
magic and a strong understanding of the
dark arts additionally mechanical showed
that she is able to cast dark spells if
necessary as shown when she cast the
Imperius curse on amicus Cara without
true heartfelt intent paired with
knowledge of the dark arts and powerful
metrical capabilities this wouldn't have
been possible number four dueling coming
in at number four analyst his
McGonigle's dueling skills Minerva has
proven time and time again that she is
nothing to scoff at when it comes to
julie and has shown her proficiency in
many different circumstances whether
it's dueling the powerful Severus Snape
himself in an effort to have him leave
Hogwarts battling Voldemort to a
standstill alongside Slughorn in qingxue
or defeating Alecto Caro
in the Battle of the Astronomy tower
McGonagall has proven that she is more
than capable of handling herself if
necessary coming in at number three in
the list his mechanical skill at potion
making having always been an excellent
student in many different areas potions
was no exception
one notable potion in particular that
McGonagall was able to create was the
anim juris potion creating this potion
is thought to be an extremely difficult
and lengthy process with room for little
to no margin of error brewing this
potion incorrectly could result in
disastrous consequences I feel that if
mechanical is able to brew such a
complex potion which is likely that
she's able to brew many others with ease
which would make her potions master of
sorts number two
charms coming in at number two is
McGonigle's proficiency at casting a
wide variety of charms
McGonigle like other powerful witches
and wizards became a master of the
Patronus charm i was able to cast both a
corporeal and incorporeal Patronus the
Patronus charm is of course of defensive
spell used to defend against the mendes
and left defaults McGonigle's corporeal
Patronus took the form of a cat which of
course is the same as her Anna mages in
addition to showing particular
proficiency at casting the Patronus
charm
McGonigle was also exceptionally skilled
at casting peer totem locomotor which
brings inanimate or unmoving objects to
life mechanical most notably cast this
charm in preparation for the impending
attack on Hogwarts her immense skill at
casting it meant that she was able to
bring hundreds if not thousands of desks
and statues to life with a single
casting that's what a power shouldn't go
unnoticed and I think that it's
deserving of the number two spot
in this list number one Transfiguration
and becoming in anime jizz coming in at
number one is of course mechanicals
extreme skill at transforming her
physical form this is achieved through
her knowledge of Transfiguration and her
capabilities as an anime giuse
Transfiguration is of course the art of
changing the form or appearance of an
object or person and an anime giuse is a
witch a wizard that is able to transform
themselves into an animal and back again
it is an extremely rare skill and it is
required of all anime G to register this
ability mechanical and a majors form as
tabby cat and she was known to use his
ability when she didn't want to be
recognized or noticed
McGonigle was extremely proficient at
transfiguration even in her school days
and aced both her owls and newts and the
subject she later became
transfiguration at hogwarts a position
that she took very seriously as she
believed transfiguration to be one of
the most complex and dangerous forms of
magic taught at school
McGonigle was one of the professor's
entrusted with the responsibility of
protecting the philosopher's stone her
contribution to this protection was
enlarging an entire chess set to a giant
size and having them come to life due to
the complexity of this branch of magic
and McGonigle's mastery
I felt that it deserved the number one
spot on this list what do you guys think
do you get with this list this list was
a little harder to make than the others
as McGonagall is not actively shown
using magic as much of some of the other
characters if there's something that
I've missed out or if there's a
replacement that you'd make please let
me know down in the comment section
below and remember help will always be
given at Hogwarts to those who deserve
it
[Music]